Here are some tips for knitting socks.
I'm knitting a small Christmas stocking,
but the techniques are the same.
First,
when you cast on,
no matter what edge you use ribbing or
not, leave a long tail
to use for seaming your sock.
To reduce the number of yarn ends.
Plan ahead when creating
your toes and heels.
If your heel is going to be the same color
as the rest of your sock
and you are instructed to work the heel
on the opposite side from the carriage,
notice that the working yarn is
not going to be in position
to knit the heel.
You could break the yarn and put
these needles in hold position,
rethread the carriage and work the heel.
But you'd have an extra yarn end.
Consider un-knitting one row the needles
that are going to be held.
Positioning that working
yarn next to the heel.
Then work the heel and when it's complete,
knit across all the needles.
This eliminates that extra yarn tail.
If your heel is going to be
knit in a second color,
remove the working yarn
from the carriage and secure it.
Free pass over to the heel side.
Since all the needles
are in working position, I just set
my carriage to slip and did a free pass.
Put the needles in hold as instructed.
Thread up the heel color yarn
and short-row shape the heel.
Now notice I'm using my thumb to make
sure that those stitches don't pop off.
You can use a weight, but manually
holding them in place works pretty
well.
We'll end up with the carriage
on the left in this instance.
Now here's another trick.
Notice how those stitches
on the left are really sloppy.
I'm going to tighten them up and secure
them, but pick up the heel of that first
stitch of the row below.
In my case, this little red stitch,
I'm going to pick that up
and hang it on the needle.
This will help secure that loose edge.
To finish up this contrast color heel,
I'll break my white yarn
and notice that the red yarn -  my working
yarn is over there on the right.
So I'm going to need to free pass.
This time I'll put all
the needles in hold.
My carriage is still
in hold from the short rows.
Free pass over
and my carriage will be on the side of my
working yarn and I can continue knitting.
Here is the short row
shaping at a larger gauge.
It'll be easier to see
when we first knit across.
It should be really clear
why we wrap when we do short rows.
Picture this:
we're going to pass the carriage and that
working yarn back again to the right.
Can you see where a hole is going to form?
By taking the working yarn and wrapping
the needle next to that last
stitch will prevent a hole.
This is a manual wrap.
I'll now stitch to an automatic wrap
by putting the needle next
to the carriage into hold position.
You can see the wrap and the strand
isn't pulling and creating a hole.
In addition to staying on track
and wrapping each time,
keeping the stitches forming correctly is
the trickiest part
of knitting heels and toes.
Because the knitting is building
up in the middle, the stitches tend
to jump up and not form properly.
Use a weight and your fingers
whatever you need to do
to keep things knitting smoothly.
When it's time to start putting needles
back into working position,
next to the carriage
we'll hold the last stitch
and put a needle opposite
the carriage into work
and knit across.
Then we'll continue putting needles
back into work until all needles are
in working position, completing the heel.
Just like before,
we can see that the stitch on the edge
where we started knitting
can get really sloppy.
By picking up the heel of the stitch from
the row below, you'll tighten things up.
I cut the white yarn,
put all of the needles into hold.
The carriage is still set to hold
and I can free pass back over to the other
side where the working yarn,
the red working yarn is sitting there
waiting to continue knitting my sock.
This along with neat seaming
and you'll be hole free.